اذا لا تزال هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه على
قطاع غزه مستمره ونحن نقترب من اليوم ال
ولكن لا تزال المقاومه الفلسطينيه تضرب من
مسافه صفر وتعود مناطق غريبه لهذه
المواجهات ونتحدث عن المنطقه الشماليه مع
انسحابات لافته للنظر في مقابل مقاومه
وقتال من المسافه صفر في المنطقه الشماليه
اذ اعلنت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بانها
انسحبت من مناطق في المناطق الشماليه
وكذلك رصد صحفيون وناشطون انسحاب قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من مناطق في المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه من قطاع غزه ومن مدينه
غزه كنا نعلم ان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مع بدايه التوغل البري في ال 27 تقريبا من
اكتوبر قد دخلت الى هذه المناطق وتوغلت في
عمق حوالي كيلو متر بهذا الاتجاه تقريبا
او اكثر قليلا ومن ثم توغلت ايضا بالتوازي
مع ذلك في القاطع الشمالي الغربي وصولا
الى مناطق اطراف الشيخ رضوان واطراف مخيم
الشاطئ ومنطقه توام واطراف النصر في
المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه اليوم قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تنسحب من هذه المنطقه
وكان هناك اثار لدمار كبير اثرى هذا
الانسحاب بعد عمليه الانسحاب بطبيعه الحال
المناطق التي انسحبت منها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كانت في هذه القواطع المهمه
منطقه توام منطقه النصر اطراف الشاطئ
ابراج الكرامه ابراج المجوسي في هذه
المنطقه و وصولا الى الصفطاوي ومنطقه
السلاطين ايضا التي سحبت منها قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وصولا ايضا الى منطقه
العطاط في المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه هذا
يعني ان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لا يعلم
لا يعلم حتى هذه اللحظه ان كانت تتمركز في
المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه من او المنطقه
الشماليه من قطاع غزه اي اننا نتحدث عن
هذه المناطق والمساحات الفارغه التي كانت
قد توغلت فيها في بدايه او في في بدايه
التوغل البري في نهايه شهر اكتوبر اذا هذا
الانسحاب من هذه المنطقه هو انسحاب لافه
النظر ونحن نتحدث عن حوالي عمق بهذا
الاتجاه حوالي كيلو الى كيلو ونصف تقريبا
من جهه الشرق نحو الغرب في هذه المنطقه
ونتحدث ايضا عن انسحاب يصل الى حوالي 2
ونص الى 3 م تقريبا من المنطقه التي
انسحبت منها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي او
اكثر من 3 م تقريبا في هذه المنطقه اذا
هذا هو المربع باللون الازرق الذي انسحبت
منه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه ولكن الاشتباكات
لا تزال المستمره في القاطع الشمالي من
قطاع غزه وعندما نتحدث عن القاطع الشمالي
نتحدث عن المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه من
مدينه غزه اذ ان قوات الاحتلال تتمركز عند
شارع 10ش في المنطقه الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه
وتضرب من الجهه الجنوبيه تتمركز بهذا
الشكل تقريبا اطراف حي الزيتون اطراف
الشيخ عجلين في هذه بهذا الشكل وتتقدم
وتنا في منطقه تل الهواء خلال الايام
الساعات القرينه الماضيه 24 48 ساعه
الماضيه كان هناك قتال من المسافه صفر
وكنا قد شاهدنا اعلان كتاب القسام عن قنص
ضابط اسرائيلي برته رائد في وحده تشل داغ
الاستخباراتيه في منطقه تل الهواء واليوم
اعلنت القسام او نشرت القسام مقطع فيديو
لاصابه هذا الضابط بمقتل في منطقه تل
الهواء اذا لا تزال منطقه تل الهواء في
المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه تشهد اشتباكات
وقتال عنيف منين المقاومه الفلسطينيه من
جهه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من جهه ما
تزال في المنطقه الجنوبيه والقاطع الجنوبي
وتحديدا الجنوب الغربي من مدينه غزه هذا
الامر ينسحب ايضا على المنطقه الجنوبيه من
قطاع غزه عندما نتحدث عن خان يونس رغم
الانسحابات اذا اعلن قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عن سحب اي لواء مظليين لواء
مظليين 55 من المنطقه الغربيه ولكن
المنطقه الغربيه لا تزال تشهد اعنف
المعارك بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال اعنى كتاب القسام وسرا القدس عن
استهداف لاليات عسكريه اسرائيليه تحديدا
في منطقه مخيم خانيونس كما نشاهد ومنطقه
اطراف حي الامن في المنطقه الشماليه
الغربيه وهذه المنطقه منطقه مخيم خانيونس
لا تزال تشهد عمليات عسكريه للجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي رغمه تنفيذه بعض
الانسحابات الجزئيه في هذه المنطقه من
اطراف خانيونس ولكن هذه المنطقه لا تزال
تشهد اشتباكات عنيفه بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال اذا نتحدث عن
محورين اساسيين للقتال المنطقه الشماليه
من قطاع غزه تحديدا المنطقه الجنوبيه
الغربيه من مدينه غزه منطقه الهواء محيطها
ومنطقه الغربيه تحديدا من خان يونس في
المنطقه الجنوبيه من قطاع غزه هذه
التفاصيل بطبيعه الحال تتحرك بشكل متسارع
ولكن هذه هي ابرز التطو في قطاع غزه خلال
الساعات ال 24 الماضيه